close your eyes I want you to picture
the knowledge that's in your head right
now can you feel it one way I can probe
your knowledge is by asking you
questions that is things you can know
without leaving your chair without
interacting with the world in any way
none of your senses are allowed do you
think this collection of knowledge can
grow just by sitting there pondering to
yourself now you can open your eyes
the process of going from question to a
definite answer is at the root of logic
logic explores arguments for truth when
we walk this pathway from question to
answer
we call it reasoning and logic is the
study of sequences of reasoning a big
reason why Aristotle's ideas on logic
matter today is because he steered the
subject in what we'd now call the modern
direction he wanted to define perfect
arguments for truth so he looked for
general patterns that is things that
make something true no matter what
subject you are thinking of this is
called abstract thought but what exactly
is abstraction close your eyes one more
time imagine a tree you've never seen
now you have some abstract concept of
tree in your head which was just
activated it's abstract because it's not
a memory of a tree you've seen in the
past it's a more general concept or
feeling of what you associate with Trena
s-- with it you can generate new trees
in your mind you've never seen before
now open your eyes your idea of tree is
general enough to fit with any specific
tree I show you you can carry all trees
in your head that's abstraction killed
Ranbir acting when they come to
understand shapes and numbers as
categories can you make two towers
and words or symbols act as the bridge
between physical things and abstract
concepts for example as a child you
memorize the word tree perhaps using a
specific example but tree became a label
for your tree category for Aristotle it
was important to separate these abstract
categories from specific physical things
in our world
he called this physical matter the
primary substance and the abstract
categories in our mind as the secondary
substance you also have another word
human which defines this abstract
category which all people have existed
and will exist belong to what's
important to see here is that the human
category and the tree category don't
contain any shared stuff there are no
human trees but abstract categories can
contain each other for example mortality
contains both trees and humans so these
are the categories which Aristotle
describes as secondary substances and
often when we are making statements
about the world we are actually just
expressing connections between
categories and Aristotle shows this with
a very simple example known as a
proposition of the forum all something
are something such as all humans are
mortal
remember when we make this claim we are
saying that all things we could point to
in the physical world will follow this
pattern while the opposite isn't
necessarily true
so these statements are like building
blocks for Aristotle his whole system is
built on a very simple rule about them
valid statements must be true or false
but never both true and false at the
same time known as the law of
non-contradiction next he shows how we
can then combine these statements to
build new
Booth's and his idea is based on how we
argue that something is true or not if
we try to make a logical argument that
means we are arranging a sequence of
statements people already agree on as
true and build to the statement in
question he thought of this as a perfect
argument since there is never a step
where things break down known as
deduction a common example how can we
prove that the statement all Greeks are
mortal is true to answer this
deductively aristotle uses a conditional
statement as the framework which leads
to the following form if all statement
one and all statement two then all
statement three
and he puts the statement we want to
prove as true at the bottom of this
sequence the process of deduction is to
fill in statement one and two using
knowledge which is already agreed on as
true so one thing we already know is all
humans are mortal now we just need
another statement which helps us connect
Greek nostalgia our human if all Greeks
are human and all humans are mortal
then all Greeks are mortal the first two
statements are known as the premise of
our argument and the third is the
logical conclusion if we can agree that
the premises are true then the
conclusion must follow this is known as
a syllogism but Aristotle only use
specific examples to get people to his
core idea his big leap was to see that
we only need to look at the structure of
the words not the content of the words
remember your way of representing the
category Greek could be this combination
of letters in English or maybe you
represent it as the color blue in some
sort of color language so now let's put
together the same argument using this
color system notice the colors bring out
the pattern to his system more clearly
we connect Bluegreen concepts using a
shared yellow concept known as the
middle term so the final step aristotle
took was to remove the content of this
argument from the form that is forget
what the colors even represent think of
them as variables so any words or
categories you choose to replace the
colors blue yellow and green will still
result in a valid argument leading to
some true statement try it
syllogisms while simple are important
because they act as building blocks for
even more complex arguments allowing us
to chain together statements which
connect and quantify any abstract ideas
we want
logic allows us to reason about the
world abstractly without any physical
basis we can just sit in our chairs and
expend energy on abstractions but what
is the limit of logic that is are there
some true statements which are out of
reach of logic